a New York City Art Gallery unveiling a
new painting by Hunter Biden and the
asking price is 225 thousand dollars
Jimmy Bayla is the host of fox Across
America that's a lot that sets big money
and if you think the price is high you
should meet the painter hey everybody
good to see you come on now but the
reason this is it does look bad like no
Administration has ever cared less about
Optics than this one because I think the
belief is they don't expect backlash
from the Press but understand prior to
Joe Biden becoming the president there
was no market for Hunter Biden okay he
wasn't a known commodity in the art
world the only thing he was known for
forgive me is painting the town okay
there was no demand for this so it looks
a little ridiculous that they might be
peddling a little influence here and
this very much overlaps with the
accusation in the hunter Biden laptop
that these guys just traded on the name
at the very least they seem to be doing
that here your two for two in answer
number one that's like his version of
starry starry night so apparently the
guy running the gallery says Hunter's
been a painter for a year he's an oddest
yeah okay he's always been an artist but
there was a difference between painting
on your own and saying okay that's all
I'm going to do and I'm just going to be
an odd yeah I don't buy that okay
they're not like taking a company public
everybody wanted a piece of but the one
thing is it's only 200 000 for Hunter
because he's got to give 10 of the sale
to the big there it is
number two Nancy Pelosi's he's
apparently says her mom is tough to
crack listen here sound bite watch oh
there's no cutting her off guard my
life's work has been trying to get her
to go off guard but it doesn't happen
she eats nails for breakfast
and ice cream in the afternoon
fancy ice cream do you remember that
nice Pine she had during the lockdown
everyone stay home while I eat a 32 pint
of ice cream uh the thing I like about
HBO though is they chose a director that
clearly didn't have a horse in this race
clearly she has no interest in pushing
the subject I mean I thought it was a
little ridiculous I don't doubt people
will enjoy this because Nancy Pelosi is
Iconic I disagree with her but she's
great at a job she's very good at
getting the votes but I wouldn't watch
this at gunpoint let me ask you about
this um Elon Musk going on yeah top
going on the on the record of how he
feels about Dr Anthony fauci he tweeted
this my pronouns are prosecute slash
fauci and then there's a picture that he
did that really got the folks upset
saying just one more lockdown my king I
don't even know where he's coming on
that but also on a serious note he is
releasing this information that Jupiter
throttled down anyone who they didn't
agree with on science yeah well it's
interesting because obviously you know
know what fauci and what he represents
here okay and what Elon is trying to do
there's some overlap and what I mean by
this just so it clears I think this is
an unforced arrow by Elon Musk because
the reason he's showing the light of day
to all of these internal censorship
efforts was to prove how corrupt the
previous regime was he is now
simultaneously inserting himself into
this debate by taking what many consider
to be a political position so I don't
know that this was the right move but I
find it really funny and after the
weekend I had in Oklahoma City I'm just
glad no one is calling to prosecute me
okay that's it there's time with the
statute of limitations yes inspired you
oh thanks Hammer thanks for nothing
Sheriff knocking on you I guess you're
never going back to Oklahoma no time
soon Jimmy thank you hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here here on YouTube so subscribe
right now